Vikings Valhalla season 2 comes to an
explosive end but the future is a
Freitas Harold and Leif are anything but
insured the events of this season have
forever changed the fate of the Vikings
the first episode of Vikings Valhalla
season 2 introduces the yams Vikings a
group of Viking mercenaries and Pirates
feared an equal measure for both their
battle prowess and ruthlessness they
were a real group of historical Vikings
or at least a real Viking myth and at
one point Olof Haroldson actually
references one of their historically
attested leaders thorkel the tall in the
series however they are led by the
fictional Lord haraker who ensures the
fierce Raiders rigidly adhere to their
own selfish merciless code that is until
Freitas arrives in their capital city of
yomsburg following freitas's arrival her
preceding reputation and her subsequent
string of valiant Deeds combined to earn
her a place as the religious head of
yomsburg and then eventually its
Undisputed leader after many lengthy
conflicts with herricker and his most
loyal yums Vikings including multiple
attempts on herricker's part to murder
Freitas and kidnap her newborn's son
Freitas prevails earning absolute faith
and respect from Yum's board's citizens
and the remaining yams Vikings this
represents a complete 180 for yomsburg
and its people who until then had only
known pillaging and marauding as a means
of survival following freitas's
Ascension to the head of yomsburg the
people jump at the chance to live
peacefully
when season 2 begins Freitas and Harold
bid each other a solemn goodbye as they
part ways on their own missions
unbeknownst to Harold Freitas became
pregnant with his child just before his
departure and chose to hide the news
knowing that Harold would abandon his
quest if he knew the mission to Rally an
army and retake the capital city of
catagats is too important to be
abandoned even for the sake of their
future family from the moment Freitas
learns of her pregnancy the child brings
trouble to her Harold Leif and many
others in the Viking world and it only
gets worse once he's born the boy named
Harold after his father is kidnapped
mere moments after his birth and used as
a political pawn and that occurs despite
his existence being a secret to all but
the people of yomsburg if his true
lineage as the son of the prince of
Norway and claimant to the throne were
to leak his life along with all of those
nearest to him would be in even greater
Danger despite being aware of this
Freitas brings him before Queen elificu
and uses him as a tool to invoke the
Queen's sympathy and win a promise of
Peace you have my word
mother to mother
at the end of Vikings Valhalla season
one fans likely considered Godwin the
Earl of Wessex as little more than a
scheming sycophant due in no small part
to the way he ruthlessly murdered a
defenseless child who considered him a
close friend season 2 gives us a closer
look into the depths of Godwin's soul
and by its end it may have won the
majority of fans over and he has Queen
Emma of Normandy to thank for it
throughout season 2 we see Godwin head
over heels in love with alfwin one of
Emma's attendants he's tender loving and
genuine but all of this comes to an
abrupt halt when Emma suspects both he
and Alf win of a conspiracy to
assassinate her you must keep this
business a secret from the queen
found out about us she would send you
away she tortures elf win for
information inadvertently pushing too
hard and killing her in the process in
consolation and to prevent political
turmoil Emma's husband King knut
arranges a new marriage for Godwin this
time to his niece Gita then even knowing
she was wrong in her suspicions Emma
can't resist one final strike against
Godwin she tracks down the ring that
belonged to Godwin's disgraced father
mounts it on a necklace chain and orders
Gita to wear it always so the Godwin
will forever be reminded of his past
season 2 features several major triumphs
on behalf of the main Trio of Freitas
Leif and Harold much to their delight
and certainly also to the Delight of
fans among those one of the purest and
most emotional is how life is finally
able to begin shedding some of his
deep-seated animal rage throughout
season one leif's barbarian rage
consumed him whenever he or his loved
ones faced danger and for all the good
it did in saving their lives it also ate
away at his soul more than once he found
himself suddenly in control of lost
senses literally covered in blood and
unable to easily control himself in
season 2 life grows beyond some of this
and it is all thanks to Miriam lathe
meets Miriam in Novgorod and she joins
the party journeying to Constantinople
during their travels Miriam and Leif
become closer and closer eventually
growing to love each other as life gets
to know her he discovers she possesses
remarkable intelligence Miriam teaches
life math astronomy and how to read and
write in multiple languages including
Arabic Greek and Latin through the art
of learning Leif discovers that he can
evolve and better himself and that there
is much more Harmony and Beauty in the
world than he could have ever imagined
similarly as season one of Vikings
Valhalla concluded with a battle for
control of ketegat season 2 ends with a
climactic fight for control of yomsburg
in addition to the geopolitical
importance of the conflict it's also the
culmination of a personal Vendetta
between Freitas and Olaf and a major
turning point in the battle between
Christian Vikings and Pagan Vikings the
momentous occasion ends with Freitas the
Victor in every aspect but the opposite
would have come true if not for the
actions and sacrifice of the yams viking
named urinder urander is an important
but odd figure in the architecture of
the Season he first appears in episode 1
and brings Freitas to yomsburg setting
in motion her whole Arc after that he's
forced to play both sides of the
conflict between Freitas and harika for
the political and religious control of
the city because of this major players
on both sides label him a traitor and
even go so far as to cut off his hand
and banish him from the city forever in
an incredible twist of fate he happens
to run into Olaf while he's sailing to
take yomsburg and kill Freitas granting
jorinder the opportunity to sabotage
Olaf's Fleet and save the lives of
Freitas baby Harold yamsborg and
potentially the entirety of pagan
vikingdom
a huge part of freitas's role in season
two is a transformation from a deadly
Shield Maiden to an inspirational
Prophet or as she comes to be known The
Keeper of the faith it's one more big
step on her long journey from unassuming
Backwoods greenlander to Legendary
Viking ruler and naturally it means
trading in some of her swordplay for
statecraft as season 2 ends however we
get one more look at the cunning
ferocious Shield Maiden Freitas we got
to know in season one and it leads to
the total Destruction of Olaf's Fleet
and army without her people
who is she waiting for
me
building off of urender's sacrifice
which gave Olaf and his Fleet the false
impression that they were clear to enter
the Bay of the armsburg Freitas calmly
allows the fleet to fill the bay even
letting them pull up to the city's docks
then her Brilliance begins to reveal
itself as a series of submerged urns
begin to open and the Waters of the bay
begin to turn black unbeknownst to Olaf
and his men the waters in which they
float are now slick with oil and with
one casual flick of a lit Torch from
Freitas the entirety of Olaf's Fleet
Burns to Cinders it's refreshing to see
that the new Pious Freitas is every bit
the tactician she used to be
on the one hand Olaf is a nuanced
compelling character and we want to see
him in as many vikings Valhalla stories
as possible on the other hand however
Olaf has been a callous monster who
murdered Pagan's wholesale and tormented
Freitas sometimes just for fun and we
are more than justified in craving his
comeuppance paying off the story that
began back in the first episode of the
series Olaf does indeed receive his Just
Desserts and it's a suitably grisly
series of assaults with his ships burnt
and his men dead Olaf engages Freitas in
one-on-one combat he's an expert fighter
has a substantial advantage over Freitas
and size and strength and has the added
edge of freitas's weaknesses after
having given birth so recently
nonetheless she beats Olaf killing him
by running a spear through him sideways
skewering his heart and lungs in the
process her vengeance is sweet and long
overdue as much as we'll miss Olaf the
ending of season two is better for
providing closure to such an extended
storyline
hundreds of miles from the Viking
territories of England and Norway lathe
Herald and a Motley Crew of sailors and
slaves Brave the niper river to travel
from navgarad to Constantinople the
journey is a long one filled with deadly
ice flows and even deadlier enemy
Raiders and many of those that set out
with Leif and Harold didn't survive for
long those that do survive however form
strong bonds and in the case of Harold
and the nobleman's daughter named Elena
the bond turns into love despite
Harold's relationship with Freitas and
perhaps partially because she kept their
child a secret from him the Viking
eventually falls for the Young Atlanta
making love to her and sharing several
intimate moments though Harold had
assumed Elena a relatively unimportant
figure politically she is revealed as
the exact opposite just as the crew is
about to reach Constantinople Harold is
unexpectedly greeted by the great City's
Emperor who reveals Elena to be his his
new Empress she reveals herself to
Harold holding herself proudly and
Shining an extravagant jewelry and robes
for Harold who made the difficult choice
to betray his love for Freitas to pursue
Elena the news that she's to be married
to one of the most powerful people on
the planet comes as a heavy blow one
that is unlikely to heal anytime soon
with Freitas in charge of yomsburg
having transformed the city into a Haven
for Pagan Vikings and raising the son of
the prince there the city has rapidly
become a major power in the Viking World
though not of a similar size and
population As Cities like katagat and
London yomsburg has become as important
and influential as the rest due to its
religious significance and the royalty
that calls it home despite its
importance the newly reworked version of
the city is very young and that makes it
vulnerable in her final act in season 2
Freitas secures peace for yomsburg and
the level to which her Mission succeeds
will undoubtedly set the stage for a
potential season three in what might go
down as the single smartest strategic
move Freitas ever makes she spots the
Young's Fame son of king knut among
Olaf's forces and coaxes him into
debarking from his ship and watching her
battle with Olaf up close in doing so
she saves him from burning in her oily
trap thereby saving herself and her
people from becoming enemies of the
mighty Canute what does it say in your
thought
a destiny to protect those who worship
the old gods
her Brilliance continues when she
escorts its Fame to his mother Queen
alafigu and katagat granting her the
gift of her son's life in exchange for a
promise of peace between the fledgling
yomsburg and the tremendous might of
Norway
though season two ends with a breath of
fresh air several factors threatened to
punch our protagonists in the gut and
knock that wind right out of them sooner
or later and Freitas and Harold lie at
the center of almost every one of them
Freitas won a huge Victory when she
killed Olaf but he was Harold's
half-brother for all the animosity
between the two men they both live
within the Viking ethos meaning both
care deeply for their honor and that of
their family Harold may not take the
news of his half-brother's death lightly
especially when it is combined with the
fact that Freitas just secured peace
with katigat the exact City that Harold
is set on conquering adding further
wrinkles to their relationship are
freitas's decision to hide Harold's son
from him and Harold's infidelity with
Elena Elena has made it very clear to
Harold that despite her marriage to the
emperor she wants their Affair to
continue which if discovered could
quickly turn the mighty Constantinople
from friend to foe even if none of these
potential disasters come to pass Anne
Freitas and Harold once again become a
united front against catagat that still
pits them against king knut queen
alephagu queen Emma and the combined
might of most of the Viking world that
makes the ending of Vikings Valhalla
season 2 The call before one cold
catastrophic storm or another
[Music]